hello YouTube chest llamas this is
Virginia and I haven't done a chest
video for a while so I thought I might
start with a nice series of chess
puzzles okay have a look with this
puzzle it's white to move and what do
you think who's gonna win this game
let's start first with whites position
over here White has a two pair of bishop
but they are just a drunk bishop they
are not doing anything they're just
sitting aside not joining any kind of
party where if you can look at the
blacks position here let me flip the
view black has a pawn on the edge file
which is rushing through for the Queen
and it literally is shocking to the
white species that somebody stop me so
what do you think which side gonna win
here before going further in the puzzle
let me remind you that if any time
during my puzzle you think that you
require more time or you require more
analyzation you can pause the video
because it's really boring for me to
stop and give you some more times so
please feel free to pause the video if
you think that you require more pawns
more time for this puzzle okay if you if
you pick the black side here you are
wrong because in this puzzle white gonna
win in all kinds of cases and you might
wondering how I'd gonna stop that pawn
well that's this puzzle is all about
okay what do you think what's white
gotta whites first gonna play like what
will be the first move of the white the
first move the white here is really
quite move which is moving this pawn
further okay let's take the first option
which is the but obvious response of the
black is try to queening that point as
quickly as possible so black will move
that pawn further well here black will
fall into a nice trap by white which is
fight we'll take this bond and hear if
the black will continue with the
queening the bond then white will check
the black Ming and now if the black King
take the pawn white will again move this
pawn and make the Queen and check to the
black King and now if if the King take
this Queen you can already see the pawn
which block that diagonal for the bishop
is not open and simply this Bishop can
take the Queen and it's just your one
pawn was his one pawn and white has two
bishops so it's really easy win for the
white okay let's take a second option
we're here in this position instead of
queening the pawn what happens if the
black King sorry black pawn take this
white pawn well here white has a nice
move which is moving King further and
giving her back side bishop or breathing
room so what will be the black sighs
moans over here keep the black with
Queen this pawn then what what why I
gonna do is giving a check to the team
and when the King moving aside White
will queen his phone and now when the
king is going aside I can simply take
the Queen so that's the second option
but you might ask yourself what happens
in this case if the black straight away
take the pawn we're still what has a
nice move which is moving the King
further and again but obvious response
of the black will be try to move the
phone and to become a queen and in this
case white will put the bishop over here
and anyways this bishop will not gonna
stop the Queenie
because next step will be the queening
the pawn but what it does is it will
create the same kind of move orders
which is allowing the black King to go
away from that square and in this case
white will Queen the pond and the move
orders will be same and white will take
take the black Queen and you can already
see here that white has a bishop and a
pawn but the pawn on the a file of the
black will be dying soon
as white King is sitting nearby so thank
you for watching this puzzle and I will
put more puzzles in future see ya